what do you think are the limitations of
uh large language models just to make it
explicit well I mean I think that deep
computation is not what large language
models do I mean that's just it's a
different kind of thing you know the
outer loop of a large language model if
if you're trying to do many steps in a
computation the only way you get to do
that right now is by spooling out you
know all that the whole Chain of Thought
as a bunch of words basically and you
know you can make a turing machine out
of that if you want to I just was make
doing that construction you know in
principle you can make an arbitrary
computation by just spooling out the
words but it's an it's a bizarre and
efficient way to do it
um but it's something where uh the you
know I I think that's you know sort of
the the Deep computation is it's it's
really what a humans can do quickly
large language models will probably be
able to do well anything that you can do
kind of off the top of your head type
thing is that is really you know is good
for large language models and the things
you do off the top of your head you may
not get them always right but you know
you'll it it's it's thinking it through
the same way we do but I wonder if
there's an automated way to do something
that humans do
well much faster to where it like Loops
so generate arbitrary large code bases
of Wolfram language for example
well the question is what does what do
you want the code base to do
um Escape control
and take over the world okay so you know
the thing is when people say you know we
want to build this giant thing right a
giant piece of computational language in
a sense it's sort of a failure of
computational language if the thing you
have to build in other words if we have
a description if you have a small
description
that's the thing that you represent in
computational language and then the
computer can compute from that yes so in
a sense in you know when as soon as
you're giving a description that you
know if you have to somehow make that
description something you know definite
something formal and once and and to say
to say okay I'm going to give this piece
of natural language and then it's going
to splurt out this giant formal
structure that in a sense that doesn't
that doesn't really make sense because
acceptanceofar as that piece of natural
language kind of plugs into what we
socially know so to speak it plugs into
kind of our Corpus of knowledge then you
know that's the way we're capturing a
piece of that Corpus of knowledge but
hopefully we will have done that in
computational language how do you make
it do something that's big well you know
you have to have a way to describe what
you want okay I can make it more
explicit if you want how about I just
pop into my head
um iterate
through all the members of Congress
and figure out how to convince them that
they have to
let
me
this meaning the system become president
pass all the laws that allows AI systems
to take control and be the president I
don't know so that's a very explicit
like figure out the individual life
story of each Congressman that each
senator
anybody I don't know
what's required to really kind of pass
legislation and figure out how to
control them and manipulate them get all
the information what would be the
biggest fear of this congressman and uh
in such a way that you can take action
on it in the digital space so maybe
threaten the destruction reputation or
something like this right if I can
describe what I want yeah you know to
what extent can a large language model
automate that with the help uh with the
help of the concretization of something
like Wolfram language
that makes it more
um yeah rather a long way I'm also
surprised how quickly I was able to
generate yeah yeah right an attack
that that's the here you know I I swear
I swear I did not think about this
before and it's funny how quickly which
is a very concerning thing because that
that probably this idea will probably do
quite a bit of damage and there might be
a very large number of other such ideas
well I'll give you a much more benign
version of that idea okay you're gonna
make an AI tutoring system and you know
that is a that's a benign version of
what you're saying is
um I want this person to understand this
point yes you know you're essentially
doing machine learning where the where
the where the you know the the loss
function the the thing you're trying to
get to is get the human to understand
this point and and when you do a test on
the human that they yes they correctly
understand how this or that works and I
I am confident that uh you know sort of
the large language model type technology
combined with computational language is
going to be able to do pretty pretty
well at teaching us humans things and
it's going to be an interesting
phenomenon because you know sort of
individualized teaching is is a thing
that has been kind of a you know a goal
for a long time I think we're going to
get that and I think more you know that
it has many consequences for you know
like like just you know if you know me
as an if you the AI know me tell me I'm
about to do this thing what is the what
are the three things I need to know you
know given what I already know you know
what's the what's let's say I'm I'm
looking at some paper or something right
it's it's like there's a version of this
summary of that paper that is optimized
for me so to speak and where it really
is and I think that's really going to
work it could understand the the major
gaps in your knowledge yes that if field
would actually give you uh
a deeper understanding of the topic here
right and that's a you know that's an
important thing because it really
changes actually I think you know when
when you think about education and so on
it really changes kind of what's worth
doing what's not worth doing and so on
it makes you know I know in my life I've
learned lots of different fields and you
know so I yeah I don't know every time I
always think this is the one that's
going to I'm not going to be able to
learn yeah but turns out sort of there
are sort of meta methods for learning
these things in the end
um and you know I think this this idea
that it becomes easier to you know it
becomes easier to be fed knowledge so to
speak and it becomes you know if you
need to know this particular thing you
can you know you can get taught it in an
efficient way is something I think is
sort of a an interesting feature and I
think it makes the um
you know things like the value of of big
towers of specialized knowledge become
less significant compared to the kind of
meta knowledge of sort of understanding
kind of the the big picture and being
able to connect things together I think
that you know there's been this huge
trend of let's be more and more
specialized because we have to you know
we we have to sort of Ascend these
towers of knowledge but by the time you
can get you know more automation of
being able to get to that place on the
tower without having to go through all
those steps I think it sort of changes
that picture interesting so your
intuition is that in terms of the the
the collective intelligence of the
species in the individual minds they
make up that Collective
there'll be more there will Trend
towards being generalists and being kind
of philosophers that's what I think I
think that's where the humans are going
to be useful I think that a lot of these
kind of
the drilling the the the mechanical
working out of things is much more
automatable it's much more ai ai
territory so to speak no more phds
well that's a it's interesting yes I
mean that you know the the kind of the
specialization this kind of tower of
specialization which has been a feature
of you know we've accumulated lots of
knowledge in our in our species and and
you know in a sense every time we every
time we have a kind of automation a
building of tools it becomes less
necessary to know that whole Tower and
it becomes something where you can just
use a tool to get to the top of that
Tower I I think that um uh you know the
thing that is ultimately you know when
we think about okay what do the AIS do
versus what do the humans do it's like
ai's you tell them you say go achieve
this particular objective okay they can
maybe figure out a way to achieve that
objective we say what objective would
you like to achieve
the AI has no intrinsic idea of that
it's not a defined thing that's a thing
which has to come from some other you
know some other entity and insofar as we
are in charge so to speak or whatever it
is and our kind of web of society and
history and so on is the thing that is
defining what objective we want to go to
that's you know that that's that's the
thing that we humans are necessarily
involved in so to push back a little bit
don't you think that GPT feature
versions of GPT
would be able to give a good answer to
what objective would you like to achieve
from on what basis I mean if they say
look here's the terrible thing that
could happen Okay that taking the
average of the internet and they're
saying you know from the average of the
internet what do people want to do well
that's the uh the Elon Musk outage of
the most entertaining outcome is the
most likely
okay
that could be um
that could be one objective
is maximize
global
entertainment the dark version of that
is drama the the good version of that is
fun
right so I mean this this question of
what uh you know if you say to the AI
um you know uh what does the species
want to achieve
yes okay there'll be an answer right
that'll be an answer it'll be what the
average of the internet says the species
wants to achieve well this this I think
you're using the word average very
Loosely there right so
I think you I think the answers will
become more and more interesting as
these language models are trained better
and better no but I mean in the end it's
a reflection back of what we've already
said
yes but it's uh there's a deeper wisdom
to the collective intelligence
presumably than each individual maybe
isn't that what we're trying to just
Society uh to have well I mean that's
that's a that's an important no that's
an interesting question I mean in you
know insofar as some of us you know work
on trying to innovate and figure out new
things and so on it is sometimes it's a
it's a complicated interplay between
sort of the individual doing the crazy
thing often some some spur so to speak
versus the collective that's trying to
do sort of the the the the high inertia
average thing and it's you know
sometimes the collective you know is is
bubbling up things that are interesting
and sometimes it's pulling down kind of
the attempt to make this kind of
innovative Direction but don't you think
the large language models would see
beyond that simplification will say
maybe intellectual and career diversity
is really important so you need the
crazy people from the outlier on the
outskirts and so like the actual what's
the purpose of this whole thing is to
explore
through this kind of dynamics that we've
been using as a human civilization which
is most of us focused on one thing and
then there's the crazy people on the
outskirts doing the opposite of that one
thing and you kind of like pull the
whole society together there's the
mainstream science and then there's the
crazy science and it's just been enough
of the history of human civilization and
maybe the AI system will be able to see
that and the more and more impressed we
are by
a language model telling us this the
more control will give it to it and the
more we'll be willing to let it run our
society and hence there's this kind of
loop where the society could be
manipulated to let the AI system run it
right well I mean look one of the things
that's sort of interesting is we might
say we always think we're making
progress but yet if you know in a sense
by by saying let's take what already
exists and use that as a model for what
should exist yeah then you know it's
interesting that for example you know
many religions have taken that point of
view there is a you know a sacred book
that got written at Timex and it defines
how people should act for all future
time and that's you know it's it's a
model that people have operated with and
in a sense you know this is a version of
that that kind of statement it's like
take the 2023 version of sort of how the
world has exposed itself
and use that to Define what the world
should do in the future but it's not
it's an imprecise definition right
because just like with religious text
and with GPT the human interpretation of
what GPT says
will be the um
uh will be the perturbation in the
system it'll be the noise it'd be full
of uncertainty it's not like GPT will
tell you exactly what to do
it'll tell you approx A Narrative of
what like uh uh you know it's like turn
the other cheek kind of narrative right
that's that's not a fully instructive
narrative well until until the AIS
control all the systems in the world
they will be able to very precisely tell
you what to do but they'll do what they
you know they'll they'll just do this or
that thing and and that and and not only
that they'll be Auto suggesting to each
person you know do this next do that
next so I think it's a it's a slightly
more prescriptive situation than one has
typically seen but you know I think this
this whole question of sort of what
what's left for the humans so to speak
to what extent do we uh you know this
idea that there is an existing kind of
Corpus of purpose for humans defined by
what's on the internet and so on that's
an important thing but then the question
of sort of as we explore what we can
think of as the computational universe
as we explore all these different
possibilities for what we could do all
these different inventions we could make
all these different things the question
is which ones do we choose to follow
those choices are the things that in a
sense if the humans want to still have
kind of human progress that's what we we
get to make those choices so to speak in
other words the the there's this idea if
you say let's take
the kind of what exists today and use
that as the determiner of all of what
there is in the future
the thing that is sort of the
opportunity for humans is there will be
many possibilities thrown up the many
different things that could happen or be
done and the insofar as we want to be in
the loop the thing that makes sense for
us to be in the loop doing is picking
which of those possibilities we want
but the degree to which there's a
feedback loop
of the idea that we're picking some
things that's becoming questionable
because we're influenced by the various
systems absolutely if that becomes more
and more source of our education and
wisdom and knowledge
right the AIS take over I mean my you
know I've thought for a long time that
you know it's the you know AR Auto
suggestion that's really the thing that
makes the AIS take over it's just then
the humans just follow you know yeah we
will no longer write emails to each
other we'll just send the auto suggested
email yeah yeah but the the thing where
humans are potentially in the loop is
when there's a choice and when there's a
choice which we could make based on our
kind of whole web of history and so on
yeah and and that's you know that's
insofar as it's all just you know
determined uh you know the humans don't
have a place and and by the way I mean
you know at some level uh you know it's
all kind of a complicated philosophical
issue because at some level the universe
is just doing what it does we are parts
of that universe that are necessarily
doing what we do so to speak yet we feel
we have sort of agency in what we're
doing and that's that's its own separate
kind of interesting issue and we also
kind of feel like we're the Final
Destination what the universe was meant
to create
uh but we very well could be and likely
are some kind of intermediate step
obviously yeah well we're we're most
certainly some intermediate step the
question is if there's some cooler more
complex more interesting uh things
that's going to be materialized
computational universe is full of such
things but in in our particular pocket
specifically if this is the best we're
gonna do or not we can make all kinds of
interesting things in the computational
universe we when we look at them we say
yeah you know that's that's a thing we
don't it doesn't really connect with our
current uh our current way of thinking
about things it's like in mathematics
you know we've got certain theorems
they're about three or four million that
human mathematicians have written down
and published and so on but they're an
infinite number of possible mathematical
theorems we just go out into the
universe of possible theorems and pick
another theorem and then people will say
well you know that's the you know they
look at it and they say I don't know
what this theorem means it's not
connected to the things that are part of
kind of the web of history that we're
dealing with you know I think one one
point to make about sort of
understanding Ai and its relationship to
us is as we have this kind of whole
infrastructure of AI is doing their
thing and doing their thing in a way
that is perhaps not readily
understandable by us humans you know you
might say that's a that's a very weird
situation how can we have built this
thing that behaves in a way that we
can't understand that's full of
computational irreducibility Etc et
cetera et cetera you know what what is
this what's it going to feel like when
the world is run by AIS whose operations
we can't understand and the thing one
realizes is actually we've seen this
before that's what happens when we exist
in the natural world the natural world
is full of things that operate according
to definite rules they have all kinds of
you know computational irreducibility we
don't understand what the natural world
is doing occasionally and you know when
you say you know are the AI is going to
wipe us out for example well it's kind
of like is the machination of the AIS
going to lead to this thing that
eventually comes and destroys the
species well we can also ask the same
thing about the natural world or the
machination of the natural world going
to eventually lead to this thing that's
going to you know make make the earth
explode or something like this those are
those are questions those are and
insofar as we think we understand what's
happening in the natural world that's a
result of Science and natural science
and so on one of the things we can
expect when there's this giant
infrastructure of the AIS is that's
where we have to kind of invent a new
kind of natural science that kind of is
the natural science that explains to us
how the AIS work it's kind of like we
can we can you know we have a I don't
know a horse or something and we're
trying to get it we're trying to you
know ride the horse and go from here to
there we don't really understand how the
horse Works inside but we can get
certain rules and certain you know
approaches that we take to persuade the
horse to go from here to there and and
and take us there and that's the same
type of thing that we're kind of dealing
with with the sort of incomprehensible
computationally irreducible AIS but we
can identify these kinds of we can find
these kind of pockets of reducibility
that we can kind of uh you know I don't
know we're grabbing onto the Mane of the
horse or something to be able to to ride
it
um or we figure out you know if we if we
do this or that to to ride the horse
that that's a a successful way to to get
it to do what what we're interested in
doing